Charlie Chaplin who won an Oscar for the
score he composed for his film limelight
said that movie music must convey more
to the audience than the camera but it
must never be more than the voice of
that camera here are the extraordinary
composers nominated for Best Original
Score
[Music]
and the Oscar goes to
ludovic books virata's
ludovic course has no formal training in
composition and orchestration childhood
accordion lessons taught him to read
music and he studied jazz as a team this
is his first Academy Award and
nomination
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well I want to pray for first of all
tribute for the power of the music and I
want to thank you and pay tribute to my
economy knees mr. Williams mr. Shaw mr.
Iglesias and Angie Murr is downstairs he
refused to submit to the zeros so I
thank you for your chair and Zimmer I
don't know if you can see it
Thank You Chuy and all the musician
tonight it's wonderful show also can I
have a ten-second smaller hands sorry I
have a little speech I'd like to thank
the Academy with this Oscar you have
given a man a special honor and to all
of you please accept me because I've got
so much love to give
I've got so much love to give to you my
wife Sarah is there a dedicated to
display portal machine to them thank you
for all Thank You Michele
you